We will now use counting
to solve a simple
probabilistic problem.
We have in our hands an ordinary
six-sided die which
we are going to roll
six times.
So this is our probabilistic
experiment.
And we're interested in the
probability of a certain
event, the event that
the six rolls result
in different numbers.
So let us give a name to that
event and call it event A. So
we wish to calculate the
probability of this event.
But before we can even get
started answering this
question, we need a
probabilistic model.
We need to make some
assumptions, and the
assumption that we're going to
make is that all outcomes of
this experiment are
equally likely.
This is going to place us within
a discrete uniform
probabilistic model so
that we can calculate
probabilities by counting.
In particular, as we discussed
earlier in this lecture, the
probability of an event A is
going to be the number of
elements of the set A, the
number of outcomes that make
event A occur, divided by the
total number of possible
outcomes, which is the
number of elements
in our sample space.
So let us start with the
denominator, and let us look
at the typical outcomes
of this experiment.
A typical outcome is something
like this sequence,
2, 3, 4, 3, 6, 2.
That's one possible outcome.
How many outcomes of this
kind are there?
Well, we have 6 choices for the
result of the first roll,
6 choices for the result of the
second roll, and so on.
And since we have a total of 6
rolls, this means that there
is a total of 6 to the 6th
power possible outcomes,
according to the Counting
Principle.
And by the way, since we have so
many possible outcomes and
we assume that they are
equally likely, the
probability of each one
of them would be 1
over 6 to the 6th.
Incidentally, that's the same
number, the same answer, you
would get if you were to assume,
instead of assuming
directly that all outcomes are
equally likely, to just assume
that the different rolls are
rolls of a fair six-sided die,
so the probability of getting a
2 is 1/6, and also that the
different rolls are independent
of each other.
So in that case, the
probability, let's say, of
this particular sequence would
be the probability of
obtaining a 2, which is 1/6,
times the probability that we
get a 3 at the next roll, which
is 1/6, times 1/6 times
1/6 and so on, and we get the
same answer, 1 over 6 to 6th.
So we see that this assumption
of all outcomes being equally
likely has an alternative
interpretation in terms of
having a fair die which is
rolled independently 6 times.
Now, let us look at the event
of interest, A. What is a
typical element of A?
A typical element of A is a
sequence of 6 rolls in which
no number gets repeated.
So, for example, it could be a
sequence of results of this
kind, where each number
appears just once.
So all the numbers appear
exactly once in this sequence.
So what we need here is
basically to have a
permutation of the numbers
1 up to 6.
So these 6 numbers have to
appear in an arbitrary order.
In how many ways can we
order 6 elements?
This is the number of
permutations of a set of 6
elements and, as we discussed
earlier, this
is equal to 6 factorial.
So we have now counted the
number of outcomes that make
event A happen, which
is 6 factorial.
And by calculating this ratio,
we have obtained the
probability of the
desired event.
You can now pause and try
to solve a problem
of a similar kind.